I'm done it oh I'm dead
all right where they call you call me
smiley book my room we sat up our game
and you join you join in my work today
13250 young but but I've really got
active like 13 14 yeah but I moved by
active house I was full of business back
then we had Zipcars
22 years 25 up into zone
all do like will they ever got life
but I was the morning sport get
claps Wow
I don't
construction I don't see the Pasadena
depo everywhere
- show you another side
I'll slip back to the wrong side maybe I
maybe that was part of God's plan is
designed and get a good look to make a
better choice it was time real choose
but between on it
hey was the first time you did prison
oh I why I was 17 years old I live in 14
years for attempted murder
mm-hmm did she lie was 25
about that people years
still my body is kind of big
though
that man concentrate
I'll still go out because I'm generally
faster
that's the point
I'd like to see nobody
see you improving their lives or to
someone else by I know that birds don't
go my hand I like that so count
could be better don't make it worse look
like that do is alone buddy no try to
test the steel go deep finally one down
you got to work
that wasn't mine kudos how much risk are
you doing wrong 14-day substrate did I
did
295 for a grab at the police pull off 10
years 9 months off of that I did a
couple years here straight violations
and you do something you get that needle
by like three or four of those at the
same time I like yeah time
you feel this you know that you know
something to see when I drop out
light housework
or etomidate
they say its rehabilitation just making
more anger because of that we have
better take numbers
and when I got out or exams I work
sometimes I do someone they got didn't
know but I see I'm doing wrong managers
the company flex real kind outline you
know maybe like how long do [ __ ] you up
getting pocket I'm [ __ ] you up watch
oh [ __ ]
put holding over here bigger the Grand
Canyon my hotel they could kill somebody
and they could work
now let's go could you put into it yeah
I was [ __ ] I'm not as kid yes I
worked you know my kids they love that
love them they cost me you know they
stole my phone I had a pony story of two
months right
[Music]
my phone's on is that musical theme of
that hello my kid I keep it I love
talking to him and I know I'm not gonna
be too much longer because I like that
it's the closest you're gonna be I
didn't get that five
the home to lose a look at these
conscripts
while Celica
we always but with a decimal watch
because we look for okay because one
person crying too much don't do nothing
driving but what about the pastor
ducking down you've seen that's high
blow by the bunch and it was so close I
could tell you the numbers that was one
that [ __ ] done that all hit my boy
two fights in the ass cheeks but I had
bullets I don't hit in that opponent
like I feel all about like I'm hitting
on him like we went up and taking off my
clothes
did I doing it feels like I am home that
I am yet to her but she's dead like I
hate forgiveness
quick rules at what time sigh whatevs
taco double-double
we're here like that
told me about him afire none of that
no mr. grandpa
oops
who shined up and grabbed capital it's
not blessed again
nobody got mad and we shoot I think you
did that cat you coward
you cat is wind and they kept telling my
shot
remember I can know do be the point yet
then I sat down for like going with he
was they generation she told that when
generations get together they like the
folks in my Romanian her she would take
over but they're not powerful enough to
take over then you got to be top of that
persona this is gonna take a look like
y'all smile again
his demonstrate he wasn't at my bow then
she gets [ __ ] up the completed fun what
Bob bye Sookie I said you know I said
kill them
today about
thank you
if I wasn't my casting and I had killed
I would buy the pocket [ __ ]
okay
it's killing something you just do move
on or is it something you carry with you
and think about a lot it's something
fixed Damien damn it wake up this wasted
like that's this I can watch it Davis
and I don't believe in friends friends
like that but a world to let you know
your God in a [ __ ]
basically this little [ __ ] fight
sleep chill so I learned a lot by the
city I do and bits the linear by this
attack looks good
and get high busy together this isn't
just the bad [ __ ] of one that gave us
away
back in a nominee [ __ ] helped us to
become what we are today movie was
eternal they stole Adams going to [ __ ]
an apple and he will make the [ __ ] that
bitch's man can't trust him so we're you
lying next to one
just when I take these can you just keep
one out
Harper keep one out isn't my clown so
you might learn something [ __ ] like you
might be sure that's it
hey you might need to kill after that
wished it did you ever regret suck the
life of gangs or violence no matter just
I do got the clips but it's too late
okay take it back I'm it that good that
can't take it back that's what it is
yeah that was good [ __ ] y'all my books
in am going to be I tell you keep T its
next cuz a dinner to go to it
they keep going T kitchen exit don't
just sit up in
that's all I need like that's Percy but
I only eat you must make it might be
incriminating I guarantee they won't
come down and looking for you
they make you a [ __ ] witness
against me I'm telling ya I'm taking